es war ein schöner tag ruhig und sonnig
die positionierung an diesem tag dem
elften september was hätte ich
eigentlich sterben sollen
[Musik]
torino delay war zur falschen zeit am
falschen ort
die strafe einfach eine reihe von
entscheidungen die sich als richtig
erwiesen und dazu führten dass ich am
leben blieb
wo ich hätte eigentlich sterben sollen
wie so viele andere warum bin ich am
leben
ich will es lieber gar nicht wissen
renault delajoux im franzose in new york
überlebte den tödlichsten terroranschlag
der geschichte
2735 menschen sterben als am 11
september 2001 zwei von terroristen
entführte flugzeuge in die türme des
world trade centers rasen um 8 uhr 46 an
diesem morgen sitzt der lounge am
schreibtisch seines büros in der 47
etage des nordturms zur gleichen zeit
fahren john pesci und colin richardson
in ihrem üblichen fahrstuhl und finden
sich kurz darauf im fünfzigsten stopp in
einem brennenden alptraum wieder
ich sage oft zu läuten du weißt nicht
was dich einmal retten wird
brian clark büro liegt genau dort wo das
zweite flugzeug in den südturm
einschlägt mitten im entfernung hat er
eine wundersame begegnung
und dann rief dieser völlig fremde
halleluja ich bin gerettet
feuerwehrmann joe jonas und seine crew
kämpfen im nordturm gegen die flammen an
jenem tag verlieren
343 seiner kameraden ihr leben ich bin
der einzige aus dieser gruppe der
beliebtheit ball anderen sterben
john pesci ryan clark und jonas 4 ganz
normale leute die an diesem tag das
unvorstellbare erleben dies ist die
geschichte des elfter september in den
worten dieser männer die an
verschiedenen orten im entfernen der
twin towers gefangen waren hier erzählen
sie von ihren persönlichen kampf ums
überleben
[Musik]
bilder vom morgen des 11 september 2001
gegen 6 uhr 30 3 stunden und 15 minuten
vor dem ersten anschlag der
wetterbericht verheißt einen herrlichen
tag brüno der ag macht sich auf den weg
zur arbeit
es war ein wirklich schöner tag ich
wohne in der 22 straße und lief zur u
bahn station an der 23 was war 7 und 15
[Musik]
der unternehmer bruno delonge fährt wie
jeden morgen mit der metro zur arbeit
die büros einer consulting firma quantum
es befinden sich auf der 47 etage im
nordturm des world trade centers
[Musik]
der court land street stetig aus dieser
bahnhof etwas besonderes befand sich
direkt im einkaufszentrum unter dem
world trade center
1973 wird das world trade center
eingeweiht ein komplex von sieben
gebäuden einer stadt in der stadt das
stolze monument der amerikanischen
wirtschaft der herbert 1200 unternehmen
und 700 geschäfte
50.000 menschen arbeiten dort täglich
werden über 100.000 besucher gezählt
die twin towers waren der bezugspunkt
für alle new yorker egal wo du dich in
der stadt befand ist die beiden türme im
süden manhattans gaben die orientierung
das world trade center funktionierte als
kompass für jeden der in new york
unterwegs waren
der nordturm mit der antenne und sein
südlicher zwilling sind mit ihrem 110
stockwerken stolze 420 meter hoch ihr
motto manche von uns werden dem himmel
nina seien um 8 uhr 15 stand ich vor den
express aufzügen
ich wollte gerade einsteigen als ich
meinen freund den fahrstuhl wachmann sei
ein großer schwarzer kerl unglaublich
sympathisch
begrüßt uns immer
auf der 44 etage stieg ich aus und lief
zehn meter den gang entlang zu den
lokalen aufzügen und
ich fuhren die 47 etage wo meine firma
quinta matisse war und ging zu meinem
büro
ich war immer stolz wenn ich meinen
namen an der tür lassen
es war mein kindheitstraum gewesen eine
eigene firma in einem der höchsten
gebäude der welt zu haben
[Musik]
der mühle blick aus dem fenster war
fantastisch an jenem morgen nahm ich mir
die zeit die aussicht zu genießen
es war wirklich ein herrlicher tag
um 8.45 sind etwa 18.000 menschen in
ihren büros oder auf dem weg zu einem
der 95 fahrstühle der twin towers
unter ihnen wie jeden tag auch john
pesci der sicherheitschef der
hafenbehörde von new york und new jersey
vor neuen betrat ich den express aufzug
ich wollte daraufhin den 67 stock ich
stieg wie üblich auf der 44 etage in
einen der lokalen lifts um von dort ging
es rauf in die 67 etage
unter den anderen stammgästen des stuhls
ist auch der bauingenieur colin
richardson
ich frühstückte unten in der cafeteria
und fuhr dann rauf in den 44 stock wo
ich immer und stieg
im lift sage ich ein paar bekannte
gesichter einen kollegen aus der
straßenbaubehörde und einen
fensterputzer der mir häufiger im
gebäude begegnete
jetzt stand er mit mir im fahrstuhl samt
seinem eimer und dem abziehen der
aufzug bewegte sich wir fuhren nach oben
ich lass meine e mails als sich
plötzlich ein furchterregendes geräusch
hörte
ich blickte auf und da war das flugzeug
es krachte direkt in den turm
[Musik]
um acht uhr 43 nimmt die von terroristen
gekaperte boeing 767 der american
airlines kurs auf das world trade center
um 80 46 und 30 sekunden schlägt sie mit
750 kilometern pro stunde zwischen der
93 und 99 etage des nordturms 1
[Musik]
wenige straßenblocks entfernt im herzen
der insel manhattan liegt die feuerwache
der bekannten einheit dragon fighter aus
china town captain joe jonas kommt
gerade aus der nachtschicht als der
notruf eingeht
um 8 uhr 45 hörte ich einen großen jet
über mir dann eine laute explosion der
dienstleiter meldete sich über die
sprechanlage ein flugzeug sei gerade ins
world trade center geflogen
ich lief raus um zu schauen ob man etwas
sehen konnte tatsächlich entdeckte ich
eine riesige rauchwolke die sich quer
über den himmel zog
bryant lag arbeitet damals bei dem
finanzdienstleister europe brokers mit
büros auf der 84 etage des südturms
um 8.46 würde ich dieses laute boom boom
nicht wirklich nah aber doch zu hören
das deckenlicht flackerte ich blickte
erschrocken hoch was war passiert
dann sah ich feuer direkt hinter mir nur
ein paar meter entfernt
flammen die auf der 84 etage gegen das
glas schlugen
und dann diese unglaubliche lawine
fassaden stücke kerosin flugzeug kreiste
vielleicht auch körperteile all das
stürzt an unserem fenster vorbei und wir
sahen entsetzt
das undenkbare wird wirklichkeit binnen
sekunden verwandelt sich der nordturm in
eine feuerfalle
balotelli ist in seinem büro im 47 stock
john pesci und colin richardson sind im
lift nicht weit davon entfernt joe jonas
verlässt die fünf minuten entfernte
feuerwache ryan clark blickt aus dem
fenster im 84 stock des südturms
vielleicht fünf minuten nach dem
aufprall sein nein ich hörte schaute weg
doch ich hörte dass bereits einige aus
den fenstern den oberen stockwerken
sprangen ich wollte das auf keinen fall
mit ansehen
wenige minuten nach dem angriff stürzen
sich die ersten verzweifelten gefangen
oberhalb der brennenden stockwerke in
die tiefe
im fahrstuhl auf dem weg in die 67 etage
an alpiq auf ski und richardson noch
nicht welches drama sich draußen
abspielt dann beginnt ihre kabine zu
sinken
ich hatte den eindruck dass wir ziemlich
nah an der 67 etage war dann spürte ich
einen heftigen schlag
wir wurden gegen die wand geschleudert
das gebäude bebte als hätte es eine
explosion gegeben der lift fiel nach
unten bis er schließlich zum stehen kam
es war kein abrupter stopp es ging ganz
langsam ich nahm an dass die notbremsen
ansprang über die gegensprechanlage des
aufzugs riefen wir in der zentrale an
doch niemand antwortete
john pesci sagte wir müssen raus aus der
kabine es war offensichtlich dass wir es
auf eigene faust versuchen mussten
niemand würde kommen und uns retten
die männer im fahrstuhl wissen noch
nicht in welcher tödlichen gefahr sie
sich befinden tonnen von brennendem
kerosin stürzen die frau stuhl schächte
hinab und explodieren in der
eingangshalle am 11 september sterben
nach einer schätzung mindestens 200
menschen in den aufzügen des world trade
centers in seinem büro auf der 47 tage
ist sich bruno de longhi immer noch
nicht des ernstes der lage bewusst
der turm schwankte immer noch
meine kollegin susan im nachbarraum
fragte 'was zum teufel da los sei
ich hatte ja gesehen was geschehen war
mach dir keine sorgen sagte ich zu ihr
es war ein flugzeug
in diesem augenblick dachte ich sofort
an ein früheres kapitel der geschichte
new yorks als an einem nebligen tag in
den 40er jahren ein bomber ins empire
state building flog monika und
die 59 etage wurde am stärksten
getroffen manche hielten es für eine
japanische ballon bombe
state building steht noch das etwas so
stabiles wie das world trade center eine
konstante meines lebens einstürzen
könnte war für mich undenkbar so etwas
kann ihn nicht einmal in den sinn ich
dachte nur was für ein idiot weiß nicht
wie man ein flugzeug steuert und jetzt
verlieren wir ein paar arbeitstage es
wird alarm ausgelöst und feuerwehrleute
aus allen wachen new yorks eilen zum ort
der tragödie
von der manhattan bridge aus hatten wir
einen panoramablick auf lower manhattan
ich sage die riesigen löcher die das
flugzeug ins world trade center gerissen
hatte das feuer und den rauch der aus
dem gebäude kamen
[Musik]
mich hat dieser anblick erschüttert ein
derartiges ereignis unmittelbar an
echtzeit mitzuerleben
das nimmt einen ziemlich mit
ich fragte mich wie viele menschen jetzt
wohl meine hilfe brauchten
[Musik]
nach dem autobombenanschlag auf den
nordturm im jahr 1993 wurden
evakuierungsübungen eingeführt sie gaben
den leuten womöglich ein falsches gefühl
der sicherheit
[Musik]
die note leuchten im gebäude blinkten
und aus den lautsprechern ertönte eine
stimme meine damen und herren gebäude
zwei der südturm ist sicher sie müssen
das gebäude nicht verlassen
eine absurde anweisung während die
katastrophe im nordturm aufnimmt
[Musik]
dichter rauch drang in den aufzug wir
konnten bald kaum noch atmen es wurde
sehr schnell heiß das war wie wir später
erfuhren dass kerosin das in den etagen
über uns brannte
er sagte wir müssen hier raus
wir versuchten die fahrstuhltür
aufzudrücken
schließlich öffnete sie sich vor uns
sahen wir eine wand eine gips wand
denn zog den stil von seinem vischer ab
um damit die tür aufzuhalten
auf die wand vor und zwar die zahl 50
gesprüht wir waren also im fünfzigsten
stock
[Musik]
die männer sitzen auf der fünfzigste
etage in der falle dieses stockwerk hat
keine türen es ist eine tödliche
sackgasse ein paar ebenen tiefer bleibt
brüno de'longhi immer noch gelassen
ihr entging völlig dass ich in gefahr
war ich war davon überzeugt dass nichts
die twin towers bedrohen könnte meiner
ansicht nach waren wir absolut sicher
[Musik]
aber dann hatte ich plötzlich eine art
sechsten sinn ich weiß nicht woher das
kam bruno wir müssen hier schnell raus
ich war nicht wirklich besorgt und
rechnete damit dass wir bald
zurückkehren würden
ich sage das büro noch mal an doch sie
büro und dann schloss sich die tür ab
diese firma
um 856 erreichte jonas mit seiner crew
den fuß des nordturms in wenigen
momenten werden die einsatzkräfte die
tore zur hölle aufstoßen
wir fuhren mit dem löschfahrzeug zum
world trade center menschen rannten uns
auf der straße entgegen wie navigierten
den schlag war sie durch die massen die
vom unglücksort flohen
schließlich erreichten wir den vorderen
eingang dort waren zwei personen mit
schlimmen verbrennungen schon musste ich
die erste entscheidung treffen soll
dicht bleiben und den beiden helfen oder
nach oben gehen wo ich vielleicht
mehrere hundert menschen retten könnte
[Musik]
im 50 stock des nordturms sind john
pesci und colin richardson mit dem
fensterputzer im fahrstuhl gefangen
[Musik]
ich sage oft zu läuten du weißt nicht
was dich einmal retten wird halte immer
die augen offen
es ist komisch an jenem tag war es ein
fenster abziehen
es war bemerkenswert
ich kramte in einer aktentasche nach
irgend etwas das uns nützen könnte denn
stand neben mir er war unglaublich ruhig
natürlich hatte er genauso viel angst
wie wir einnahmen wortlos den abzieher
es war genau das richtige instrument
genau das was wir in diesem moment
brachten
so ein abzieher besteht ja aus einem
teil mit gummi und metall und einem stil
zwei teile und das metallstück das hat
natürlich eine scharfe kante
denn holte den wischer aus einem eimer
zog die klinge ab und begann damit ein
loch in die wand zu hacken er ackerte
wie besessen es sei gefährlich aus und
wir tragen einen schritt zurück dann
arbeiteten wir abwechselnd geniale idee
die klinge vom vischer abmontieren und
versuchen damit ein loch zu machen nach
einer weile war es tatsächlich so groß
dass frische luft in die aufzugs kabine
kam aber dann fiel der wischer runter
da war eine lücke ja eine kleine lücke
zwischen der kabine und der wand des
fahrstuhlschacht
die klinge warwick wir waren verzweifelt
doch dann wieder ohne ein wort zu sagen
holte aus einem eimer den griff des
wischers raus mit ihm ritzten wir ein
kreuz in die wand so tief in uhr konnten
dann tragen wir gegen die wand bis das
loch groß genug war um durch zu klettern
sie befindet sich in einem dilemma soll
er der menge der fliehende menschen
folgen oder einer eingebung vertrauen
auf dem gang saß bereits verheerend aus
alles war kaputt die taille
deckenplatten lagen auf dem boden
zusammen mit trümmern und schutt
flüssigkeit in zitaten aus den oberen
stockwerken durch es stank nach kerosin
und der rauch war so dicht dass man kaum
noch was sag ich
traf auf eine gruppe die nach unten
wollte
sie riefen zu einem treppenhaus von dem
ich zwar wusste dass wir aber bei den
evakuierungsübungen nie genutzt hatten
ein probealarm hatte man uns immer
gesagt wir sollten das mittlere
treppenhaus benutzen
dort wollte ich hin
wir machten uns alle gleichzeitig auf
den weg
die rede werde aber die anderen starben
während ich noch am leben bin
sie wiederholen
[Musik]
chelsea trifft eine entscheidung die
sein leben rettet er beginnt den langen
abstieg aus dem 47 stock die luft im
zentralen treppenhaus ist voll von
beißendem qualm und staub doch das
schlimmste steht ihm noch bevor
um 9.03 rast united airlines flug 175
mit fast 950 kilometern pro stunde in
den südturm
[Musik]
in sekundenbruchteilen verschwindet die
maschine im gebäude die 36.000 liter
treibstoff die sie an bord hat entzünden
sich in einer riesigen explosion
in diesem moment macht sich bruno de
logis im nordturm auf seinen langen weg
durchs treppenhaus john pesci und colin
richardson kämpfen sich durch die wand
im fünfzigsten stockdale jonas betritt
die eingangshalle des nordturms und auf
der 84 tage des südturms findet sich
brian clark knapp über einschlag zone
wieder
um bumm bumm bumm wieder diese doppelte
explosion der raum in dem bob und ich
uns befanden fiel einfach in sich
zusammen die deckenplatten kam runter
die leitungen der klimaanlage lampen und
lautsprecher alles passierte innerhalb
einer sekunde
ein letztes mal korrigiert die boeing
767 ihren kurs und schlägt zwischen der
77 und der 88 etage in den turm ein
ich wartete auf die anweisungen unser
des einsatzleiters die helden dem
vize-chef der ersten division hat sich
einen riesigen schatten bemerkte
dann hörte ich eine heftige detonation
unser brennende trümmer vor dem gebäude
herabstürzen
ich hatte keine ahnung was los war
vielleicht war etwas explodiert
ein mann kam von draußen rein gerannt
und sagte ein zweites flugzeug sei
soeben in den südturm gekracht in dem
moment wusste ich dass es einen anschlag
war
[Musik]
[Applaus]
für fünf sekunden schwankte das gebäude
ungefähr zwei meter nach westen
verharrte kurz und kam dann nach
weiteren fünf sekunden zurück in die
vertikale man hörte den stahl knarren
und dann eine art einrasten als er sich
wieder gesetzt hatte
da überkam mich ein gefühl und ich
dachte brian der wird nichts passieren
und ich beruhigt mich
der feuerwehrleute der ersten
rettungsmannschaft blickte hoch und
sagte kann sein dass wir das heute nicht
überleben
ich sagte da hast du recht das könnte
sein
wir richten uns die hände und wünschten
uns gegenseitig glück ich hoffe wir
sehen uns nachher wieder es ist gut zu
kennen
ich bin der einzige aus dieser gruppe
der überlebt hat alle anderen straßen
einige liefen die treppen hinab andere
ging nach oben verletzte wurden nach
unten getragen menschen mit schweren
verbrennungen auf der haut den haaren im
gesicht
jeder wusste wie ernst die lage war
trotzdem blieben alle ruhig
die leute die von oben kam freuten sich
uns zu sehen zum einen weil sie nun
wussten das zu seinen ausgang gab wenn
wir ins gebäude hinein gekommen waren
würden sie es auch verlassen können
außerdem war es für sie ein zeichen der
hoffnung
die kavallerie ist eingetroffen
wir gehen da hoch und alles wird gut
während ich nach unten um mein leben
lief ging dieser mann nach oben auf den
tod zu das machte mich fertig
[Musik]
die feuerwehrleute konnten an diesem tag
doch kaum etwas ausrichten
[Musik]
sucht diese bestenfalls ihr
pflichtbewusstsein zeigen ihren
heldenmut ihre opferbereitschaft
bis zum zeigen dass sie nicht einfach
zusehen können dass sie helfen wollen
gefangen oberhalb der einschlag zone
chart prime klagt die überlebenden um
sich gemeinsam beschließen sie trotz des
feuers den abstieg zu wagen
[Musik]
ich ging vorweg mit meiner taschen land
in der 81 etage begegnete und seine
kräftig gebaute frau sie war auf dem weg
nach oben und stellte sich mir resolut
in den weg nach unten kommt man nicht
sagte sie da unten brennt es alles
voller rauch wir müssen weiter nach oben
ein hämmern auf unserer ebene lenkte
mich ab ich hörte laute schläge und
gedämpftes rufen
hilfe ich bin gefangen ist da jemand ich
bekomme keine luft
der war kehrten meine begleiter um und
liefen wieder nach oben keiner von ihnen
hat diesen tag überlebt
während brian clark sich um den
eingeschlossenen man kümmert versuchen
seine kollegen aufs dach zu gelangen
doch die flammen drängen die
rettungshubschrauber immer wieder zurück
hilflos müssen die einsatzkräfte an bord
der helikopter die tragödie mit ansehen
in auswegloser lage und verzweifelt
stürzen sich etwa 200 menschen in die
tiefe allein zu zweit oder in gruppen
[Musik]
der mann der um hilfe rief vielleicht 20
meter entfernt ich folgte seiner stimme
um ihn zu finden er dirigierte mich
durch die dunkelheit nach links nein
hierher ziehen konnte macht nichts als
ich fast bei ihm war sagte
sehen sie meine hand und
tatsächlich unten am boden winkt aus
einem loch in der wand einer hand
ich leuchtete sie mit einer lampe an den
arm hinauf schließlich schien meine
lampe durchs loch direkt in seine augen
nicht und dann rief dieser völlig fremde
halleluja ich bin gerettet
ich sagte sie müssen über diese wand
rüber anders kommen sie da nicht raus er
sprang aber ich habe stehe nicht und
sagte sie müssen es schaffen wieder
sprang hoch und dieses mal bekam ich ihn
unter den armen zu fassen ich hob ihn
langsam an und zog ihn über die wand ein
schreibtisch kippte wir stürzten viel
auf mich und gab mir einen dankbaren
kuss
ich mich ein stück zurück staub du dich
ab und sagte ich heiße brian und erich
den stanley wir sind jetzt brüder fürs
leben
okay sagte ich wir sind brüder ich
bemerkte eine kleine wunder auf meiner
rechten hand fläche auch er hatte eine
wunde auf seiner hand dann machte ich
weiß was man in einer solchen situation
eigentlich nicht tun sollte ich rief
meine hand an seiner nun waren wir also
blutsbrüder dieser fremde und ich
noch heute ist brian clark faszinierte
nicht diese geschichte erzählt eine
wundersame geschichte stanley der
einzige überlebende aus seinem büro
glaubt dass ein engel im letzten moment
den flügel der boeing anhob um ihn zu
retten
stanley arbeitete für die fuji bank sein
büro lag im 81 stock des südturms blick
auf den hafen das telefon klingelte er
nahm ab eine frau aus der niederlassung
in chicago meldete sich ich wollte nicht
dass jemand das gespräch annimmt alle
sollten das büro verlassen darin unser
gebäude ist sicher antwortete stanley
die sie verstehen nicht ein flugzeug ist
in den nordturm geflogen sie müssen raus
er schaute aus dem fenster aus der
richtung des hafens über die
freiheitsstatue fliegend nähert er sich
die zweite maschine
er wusste nicht was geschah doch langsam
begriffen das flugzeug kam immer näher
und ihm wurde klar was passieren würde
doch er hatte glück
im letzten moment kippte die maschine
zur seite die rechte flügel spitze hob
sich die linke tragfläche neigte sich ab
dass
die bibel lang geöffnet auf dem
schreibtisch unter denen sich duckte und
rief
[Musik]
abgeschnitten von der außenwelt gefangen
im fahrstuhl auf der fünfzigsten etage
des nordturms vor sich eine gips wand
weiß john pesci dass etwas geschehen
muss
wir wussten zu dem zeitpunkt nicht ob
der fahrstuhl in seiner position bleiben
würde wir hatten tatsächlich sorge dass
die kabel durchtrennt sein könnten und
er irgendwann in die tiefe stürzen wurde
weil die notbremse sich lösen könnte
wir waren entschlossen so schnell wie
möglich da raus zu kommen
ich weiß noch wie john als antrieb er
sagte wir müssen hier heraus von dem
moment an arbeiteten wir wirklich
zusammen
wir traten gegen die wand immer und
immer wieder ich verletzte mich sogar
wie später feststellte brach ich mir
tatsächlich einen fußknochen aber wir
schafften es eine ausreichend weiter
öffnung in die mauer zu zwingen
es war ein recht großes loch vielleicht
50 mal 40 cm
nachdem wir die erste dicke schicht
durchbrochen hatten standen wir vor der
nächsten rand aber die war wesentlich
dünner als die erste
ich glaube ich war derjenige der die
zweite wand durch trat
wir schauten durch das loch und
erkannten eine damentoilette sie hatte
rosafarbene fließen über dem loch war
ein waschbecken und wir kochen
nacheinander aus dem fahrstuhl raus
ich verließ ihn als letzter dann gab ich
denn dem griff seines wischers den wirst
du eines tages haben wollen sagte ich zu
ihm er nahm ihn mit heute ist der im
museum der nine eleven gedenkstätte
ausgestellt
im südturm sitzen 619 menschen oberhalb
der 83 etage in einer tödlichen falle es
dauert 60 minuten bis der leh und brian
die 80 italien herabgestiegen sind nur
vier überlebende aus den oberen
stockwerk geschaffen es bis in die
eingangshalle wo absolutes chaos
herrscht es ist 9 uhr 59
ein feuerwehrmann sagte zu uns wenn ihr
hier raus geht müsst ihr rennen was
meinen sie fragte ich es waren trümmer
runter erklärte er und fragte soll ich
nach oben schauen denn einfach das
konnte ich aber nicht ich öffne die tür
einen spalt und zwar hoch nichts was uns
treffen könnte also fragte ich stanley
bist du bereit ich bin bereit dann sagte
ich und wir rannten wir rannten richtung
süden und zwei blocks weit bis hinter
die kirche dann stoppten wir
ist eine brach in tränen aus dieser mann
hat mein leben gerettet rief er darauf
ich stand vielleicht hat dein hilferuf
in der 81 etage mein leben gerettet
zu dem zeitpunkt standen beide türme
noch
[Musik]
im nordturm machen die menschen platz
für die rettungskräfte für die
brandopfer und andere verletzte die nach
unten kommen
es herrscht totales chaos mit rauch
gefüllten zentralen treppenhaus durch
das bruno dell lg schließlich ins freie
gelangt
[Musik]
ich ging ein paar schritte drehte mich
um und blickte hoch der turm stand in
flammen
ich traute meinen augen nicht oranges
feuer schwarzer rauch ich lief weiter
und schaute noch mal zurück ich konnte
nicht glauben welches bild sich mir bot
in diesem moment gestürzte der zweite
turm ein
um 9 uhr 59 56 minuten nach dem aufprall
kollabiert der südturm der zweite turm
der getroffen wurde fällt als erster
die spitze des gebäudes schwankte ein
wenig dann obenrum stockwerk für
stockwerk vieles in sich zusammen
[Musik]
stani und ich verließen den südturm vier
oder fünf minuten bevor er einstürzt und
wir hatten wirklich großes glück
ich überlegte wo ich mich unterstellen
könnte wenn ich schnell genug wäre anna
bligh dann sah ich einen raum mit einem
geldautomaten er war von säulen gestützt
dort wäre ich sicher glaubte ich
hab immer näher kam das monster dann
schlug es plötzlich zu ich fand mich
mitten in einem strudel von gewalt
wieder was auf der straße war wurde
gegen die fassaden geschleudert und
gegen mich dann wurde es dunkel
stellen sie sich die schwärzeste nacht
vor es war noch dunkel und
dann nichts mehr die luft war so dick
dass sich nicht mehr regte jedes
geräusch wurde geschluckt
in diesem moment dachte ich nun ist
alles vorbei ich dachte ich wäre tot
brüno de'longhi verschwindet in einer
gigantischen staubwolke währenddessen
bahnt sich captain joe jonas im nordturm
seinen weg nach oben
ich hatte den 27 stocker recht hat sich
ein lautes grollen außerhalb des
gebäudes hatte
der turm schwankte
wir fühlten uns wie auf einem schiff bei
sega
wie war klar dass uns nur noch wenig
zeit blieb das wir vielleicht nicht mehr
schaffen würden das gebäude zu verlassen
[Musik]
verwirrung wohin ich auch sah man hörte
die body talk ist der feuerwehrleiter so
viele menschen die über funk miteinander
sprachen
ich bekam mit dass alle feuerwehrleute
den befehl zum rückzug erhielten
war eine anweisung zur evakuierung
[Musik]
ich sagte meinen leuten das für unsere
mission nicht mehr erfüllen könnten und
es zeit sei das gebäude zu verlassen
um und liefen im treppenhaus des
nordturms nach unten
eine mehr als 500 meter hohe säule aus
brennend heißen rauch zersplitterte glas
und verformte metall umhüllt das gesamte
areal bruno de ski ist ein zweites mal
gefangen ganz allein hinter einer säule
in der chase bank
plötzlich sah ich einen streifen licht
ein blasses leicht gelbes leuchten in
ihm erfahren
und ich weiß nicht warum aber mir schien
dass der staub eine gelbfärbung hatte
alles war gelb vom staub
das atmen fiel mir zunehmend schwer ich
hatte das gefühl zu ersticken
ein fbi agent in der bank sah mich und
zog mich ins haus erst dort bekannt
wieder luft
[Musik]
john pesci an colin richardson sind aus
dem lift im nordturm entkommen 45
minuten dauert ihr weg ins erdgeschoss
was sie dort sehen ist apokalyptisch
[Musik]
wir erreichten die plaza habt die völlig
unter trümmern beton teilen
schreibtischen und stahlträgern begraben
lag
es hätte ein riese mit seiner hand das
world trade center zum 1
draußen vor den fenstern standen die
ersthelfer polizei und feuerwehr die
diejenigen in empfang nahmen die wie wir
das world trade center verließen man
konnte kaum etwas erkennen die menschen
waren völlig desorientiert sie packten
uns buchstäblich an den schultern und
dirigierten uns in richtung der
rettungskräfte
[Musik]
ich vermute viele dieser leute haben es
nicht überlebt
[Applaus]
eingeschlossene im gebäude
feuerwehrleute im einsatz
der tod hat mit niemandem erbarmen im
nordturm erreichen joe jonas und seine
kollegen währenddessen den 20 stock
in der zwanzigsten etage trafen wir auf
eine frau sie stand an meiner tür und
weiter es war josephine harris eine
buchhalterin der hafenbehörde sie kam
aus dem 73 stock
gemeinsam stehen wir weiter die treppe
hinab
josephine konnte sich nicht mehr auf den
beinen halten
[Musik]
die uhr tickte während wir uns bis
runter zur vierten etage vorarbeiteten
für captain joe jonas sein team und
josephine harris nur langsam vorankommt
ist es ein rennen gegen die uhr und
gegen den tod
ich hörte schreie aus der bank jemand
sagte wir sollten ins kellergeschoss
gehen saison da wo sich die saves
befinden werden wir geschützt
grupotel einige sagten der erste turm
würde einstürzen
der gedanke daran ließ mich verzweiflung
von seinem sicheren posten in der bank
aus wird brüno delon sie einen letzten
blick auf den turm in dem er seinen
amerikanischen traum gelebt hatte
die vierte etage reichten sankt josef in
paris zu boden
sie beschwor uns wir sollten ihn nicht
hoch helfen es wollte dass wir ohne sie
weitergehen
aber das konnten wir nicht
josephine harris wurde unsere mission
10 uhr 28 102 minuten nach dem einschlag
jonas und seine crew und josephine
harris sind noch in der vierten etage
als der nordturm in sich zusammenfällt
[Musik]
in nicht einmal zehn sekunden stürzen
300.000 tonnen stahl beton und glas
hunderte von beschäftigten und
feuerwehrleuten werden von den
zusammensacken geschossen erschlagen
eine todesfalle für alle die nicht
rechtzeitig fliehen konnten
ich lief gerade am wintergarten vorbei
als ein furchtbares grünen gegangen ich
drehte mich um und sah wie tom 1 des
world trade centers einstürzten
ich wollte dieses schreckliche geräusch
das entsteht wenn ein gebäude stockwerk
für stockwerk in sich zusammenfällt
die twin towers sind eine revolutionäre
konstruktion aus stahl und beton umhüllt
von fassaden aus aluminium und glas
nicht sollte ihnen etwas anhaben können
keine attacke kein anschlag nicht einmal
ein flugzeug
durch die zerstörung durch die boeing
767 die mit einer geschwindigkeit von
750 km h und 38.000 litern treibstoff im
tank in den nordturm rast ist total
binnen sekunden sind im einschlag
bereich die stahlträger des außen
skeletts und ein großteil des inneren
träger kerns zerstört
den rest erledigt das feuer temperaturen
von bis zu 1000 grad celsius halten auch
die verbliebenen pfeiler nicht mehr
stand sie klicken nach innen weg dem
eigenen gewicht nachgebend fällt der
turm in sich zusammen
dann kam die nächste katastrophe es war
der pure
drückt eine brutale schockwelle gefolgt
von dieser intensiven dunkelheit und
absoluter stille
ich machte mir auch sorgen um meine
angestellten
ich wusste nicht ob sie noch da drin
waren
tausende menschen waren tot es war
sicher
was ist passiert
es ist eingestürzt die oberen etagen
kamen montag
ich sah die explosion und rannte so
schnell ich konnte
ich bin 69
zum glück kann ich noch in
100 sechs etagen stürzen über ihnen
zusammen doch wie durch ein wunder haben
captain joe jonas seine crew und
josephine überlebt sie sind
eingeschlossen in einer blase aus beton
und trümmern im vierten stock
ich hatte keine ahnung wie es draußen
aussahen wir saßen in diesem kleinen
kokon und wir werden im leben
unmöglich dass das ganze gebäude in sich
zusammen gefallen war
captain joe jonas weiß nicht dass
oberhalb der vierten etage nichts mehr
ist der nordturm ist verschwunden
[Musik]
dass wir festsaßen wir kommen nicht raus
wir waren gefangen
normalerweise bin ich am anderen ende
ich bin einer der retter nicht jemand
der gerettet werden muss
so schlimme unwirklich dass ich nun via
funk einen notruf absetzen musste
mayday mayday mayday hier spricht der
einsatzleiter der sechsten einheit wir
sind dem nordturm treppenhaus b führte
etage wir sind gefahren
[Musik]
der mann dem ein notruf an nahm fragte
wo ist der nordturm
der nordturm ist das große gebäude an
der ecke nicht zu verführen oder
draußen versuchten sie herauszufinden wo
in diesen gigantischen schuldenberg der
neue ton war
[Musik]
[Applaus]
um 11 uhr kann captain joe jonas endlich
funkkontakt herstellen
doch es gelingt nicht seine kleine
truppe inmitten von hunderttausenden
tonnen schutt zu orten es gibt nichts
mehr woran man sich orientieren könnte
das world trade center existiert nicht
mehr
ich verließ die bank und ging nach hause
und
lag kniehoch auf der straße
alles lag auf der straße
schuhe kleidung papiere knäuel aus
stahlträgern und anderes mehr
die menschen die mir entgegenkam machten
einen großen bogen um mich oder wichen
ängstlich zurück
ich sah aus wie ein gespenst
von oben bis unten voll staub die leute
wissen vor mir zurück dabei hoffte ich
so sehr dass mich jemand in die arme
nehmen und trösten würde
[Musik]
ein ruinenfeld ein sarg aus beton und
sand im stahl für tausende pulverisierte
und verbrannte opfer menschen die von
einem moment auf den anderen nicht mehr
existieren das world trade center ist
verschwunden geblieben ist nur ein
düsterer ground zero ein trümmerfeld
niemandsland und doch geschieht mitten
in diesem chaos ein wunder
[Musik]
nach etwa vier stunden hatte sich der
rauch verzogen und der staub gelegt bei
sonnenstrahl fiel auf den boden
ich bedroht und sein stückchen blauen
himmel
ich sagte zu meinen leuten da waren mal
100 sechs stockwerke bei uns und jetzt
sehe ich die sonne ich glaube wir sind
auf dem dach des world trade centers
fünf stunden und 15 minuten nach dem
aufprall können joe jonas und seine
einsatztruppe und josephine harris
endlich aus den ruinen befreit werden
einer nach dem anderen kletterte am seil
hoch der nachholbedarf
ich suchte mir den weg zur
kommandozentrale die sich jetzt auf
einem löschfahrzeug befand
jeffrén stand oben bei den kollegen
ich stand unten und schaute zu ihm hoch
wir blickten uns allen und steigen kamen
die treiben er sagte jamie schön dich zu
sehen
ja gut hier zu sein ich salutiert und
sagte meine jungs sind durch wir sind
fertig führte klar antwortete ja geht
rüber zur ambulanz und lasst euch
versorgen
am elften september verloren 343
feuerwehrleute ihre kollegen freunde und
brüder ihr leben
[Applaus]
als erstes nahm ich eine dusche
eine ewigkeit ließ sich das heiße wasser
an mir unterlaufen
es musste eine heiße dusche sein denn
sie sollte all den schrecken die
traurigkeit und die asche abwaschen die
an mir haft
dann brachte das fernsehen die ersten
bilder
ich saß da und sah sie immer und immer
wieder
ich versuchte zu begreifen was geschehen
war
stundenlang verfolgte ich die ereignisse
zutiefst schockiert von dem was ich
erlebt hatte er ist eine und dann der
andere eine brutale orgie des terrors
und des leids die der präsident heute
abend zu rechnen versprach
hunderte von feuerwehrleuten und anderen
rettungskräften tue was sie können doch
sie kämpfen vergebens nach captain joe
jonas seiner crew und josephine harris
werden nur noch drei weitere personen
lebend geborgen
kann sagen dass wir wegen josephine
harris zur richtigen zeit am richtigen
ort waren genau dort beschloss sie nicht
weiter zu gehen um sie wären sie bereits
weiter unten gewesen wer das vorher
erreicht hatte war verloren
dort kam niemand mehr raus
die feuerwehrmänner geben josephine
harris den spitznamen unser schutzengel
zehn jahre später begleitet sie die
gesamte abteilung der logistics company
auf ihrem letzten weg
[Musik]
was wäre passiert wenn ich nach rechts
ins treppenhaus c gegangen wäre und
nicht links zum treppenhaus a was wäre
geschehen wenn wir der kräftigen frau
erst eine etage tiefer begegnet wären
dann hätte ich das stimme nicht gehört
es gibt so viele was wäre wenn fragen zu
diesem tag die sich nicht beantworten
lassen
[Musik]
in diesen schrecklichen tagen habe ich
viel gelernt über
menschlichkeit über unsere unglaubliche
fähigkeit sich den widrigkeiten zu
stellen und immer von neuem anzufangen
darauf bin ich auch ein bisschen stolz
heute 20 jahre später ist es dieser
optimismus der mich antreibt nicht der
abgrund der unmenschlichkeit indem wir
an diesem tag gelegt haben wir alle
können unser schicksal selbst bestimmen
jeder von uns hat die wahl
[Musik]
john pesci colón richardson und jonas
waren im zentrum des infernos gefangen
in den twin towers
ihr mut ihre solidarität ihr
pflichtbewusstsein und pures glück
ließen sie überleben
[Musik]